all right let's switch gears here the
economic effects of the pandemic have
left so many local families and children
especially food insecure
so you know three square is here to help
of course and you can too here's how
it's bad childhood hunger campaign it's
going into its ninth year
congratulations
thanks yeah we're really excited and
glad to continue this
campaign after such a you know
challenging year
something that continues on absolutely
so let's talk about the campaign
what do you do for the community yeah so
three square
is uh southern nevada's only food bank
and you know we provide food out into
the community but one of those
populations that we try to reach the
most vulnerable are children
and so every year this bag childhood
hunger campaign helps raise funds to
support
all of our childhood nutrition programs
um these are after-school meals
weekend meals meals during the summer
and it's just
it's a it's a vital part of what we do
right to make sure kids are getting the
proper nutrition that they need
definitely and the campaign itself is
going through may 31st correct
that's right so now through the end of
may
and we've been very fortunate that two
of our
long-standing corporate partners nevada
gold mines operated by barrick
and nv energy foundation have stepped up
to match donations
so folks that want to give back yeah can
have double that impact right now
that is incredible and speaking of
impact let's talk numbers you know what
are we seeing out there
um with childhood hunger in general and
specifically in southern nevada
sure so i mean as we i think we all know
the pandemic really took a toll
on our communities and the economy here
and so
that number of food insecure children
hit
record levels just a few weeks ago we
received some
new facts and figures where we're seeing
some improvement which is encouraging
today one out of four children lives in
a food insecure household
that's more than 131 000 children
in southern nevada that may not know
where their next meal is coming from and
so
while that number is not what it was
during the peak of the pandemic
it's still one too many right across the
valley
definitely oh so that breaks my heart so
thank god for you guys and what you're
doing um
how can other people get involved to
help the effort
yeah there's so many things you know
giving a dollar can right now can
provide up to six meals back right
because of the match
you can volunteer and all that
information can be found at
threesquared.org where you can sign up
to volunteer
or make a donation right there on the
website all right kate thank you so much
for everything you're doing for the
community for what three squares doing
for the community
let's bag childhood hunger together
right let's bag childhood hunger and
thank you so much for having us today
all right you can find the three square
food bank on north pecos road
give them a call at 702-644-3
or just visit threesquare.org